there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hey you guys it's Tuesday
again and it's time for episode 113 yeah
now this time around we have been doing
a lot of true crime episodes lately
which you know cuz I'm into that and
stuff but a couple people asked oh when
are you guys gonna go back and do some
more like paranormal type topics so I
decided to go back to a topic that had
been requested a few times a long time
ago and I've been meaning to get around
to it and we hadn't gotten around to it
but we're gonna get around to it today I
can't believe that we haven't done this
one already I can't believe it either
like this is one of the granddaddy with
conspiracies Philadelphia Experiment
and the Montauk Project which I feel
like is less well known but is related
to the Philadelphia Experiment pretty
directly I know why we didn't do this
why cuz when the show was young and new
we were trying to do subjects that were
not covered by other shows true yeah we
were trying to do more person was pretty
common so we were like now we'll blow
that off other people have done that
once but now it's time to probably
circle back around and give this the
Jenny Ashford seal of approval or just
once you know how I'm gonna roll the
thing is is that we have to claim
sources we got to tell the story about
how it starts take the truth montauk I
didn't I don't really know much about it
but Philadelphia experiment when I first
heard about it and I first heard about
it in the 80s I'd say probably mid 80s
mid to late eighties I thought maybe it
could have it there was some [ __ ] to it
that kind of but what's get into that
yeah well I think maybe some of it
happened but I think I think a lot of it
was misunderstood we'll get to that myth
that's a good way of putting it yeah
yeah all right so that's gonna be
our topic for today so it should be kind
of fun let's see we'll just do some
really quick shout outs our last movie
review was the howling so go check that
out if you haven't already if you didn't
notice on Sunday then excuse me I put up
the first episode of a new Lowell movie
review show that we're doing yeah it's
kind of in a rough stage you know what
we're gonna work on this show as we go
to find out what format works the best
yeah we just kind of decided to do it
like in that a few days later we just
kind of threw something together right
we're gonna turn it into a show as I
said on the movie review
it's basically since we're doing the
Stubbs a list program and we're seeing
three movies a week in the theater so we
decided we were just gonna do a little
capsule a little short reviews of them
while we're in the theater if we can
manage it yeah I mean try to be able to
get him out to you soon enough to where
you can take a recommendations because
we already review old movies well this
would be some new movies yeah that are
in there right now it's just that we're
not really sure whether or not we're
probably gonna polish that show and it
may take a few months
yeah just to get it right to where where
it's you know easy to do and then it
comes out slick yeah I want to be kind
of slick and fun too
yeah so so what we were gonna do is we
were gonna have like the three movies
that we saw that week we're gonna do a
little capsule reviews of them and then
at the end of the week I'll edit the
I'll edit them all together and then
I'll put it up as is like a separate
show on Sunday I'll put it in its own
little uh you know playlist in steps
just called 13 o'clock matinee with Tom
and Jenny so it's we just wanted kind of
a fun little show that made you guys
feel like you were coming to the movies
with us and then we were just kind of
like talking about the movies afterward
yeah like the first the first episode if
you haven't watched it yet turned out to
be 4045 minutes but that's because we
had an intro and we lost one of the
video feeds but then we found it again
so I just put them both in there so you
know so that's longer than you thirty
minutes
yeah we're yeah we're gonna be shooting
for like twenty thirty minutes show and
like I said I'll probably put them up on
Sundays cuz it's like beginning slash
end of the week and it'll be all the
movies that we saw the previous week
just kind of edit it all together yeah
so hopefully you guys like that that's
just something new that
we decided to do pretty much a couple
days ago like kind of just yeah we were
doing it anyway we might as well
recorded that's what we figured yeah
and other than that like I said you know
still got our patreon going and
everything like that wanted to say hi to
our newest patron who is named Denise
and also to one of our existing patrons
Tara M she actually increased her
support this past week so thank you very
much you too
also if you want your story read on our
Halloween episode
like I said fiction nonfiction as long
as it's a scary story I've got like a
[ __ ] ton a really good one so it's gonna
be like a really fun show this is
probably like your last chance to do it
we are actually going to be recording
the Halloween show
probably sometime between the 19th and
the 21st of October so if you would like
the story on the show then probably it'd
be better to get it to me before the
19th so just so we can make sure to get
it on their faces villain 2 is in the
can it is yeah I finished recording it
and I started doing the editing and I
haven't finished the editing yet but
it's all recorded so that shouldn't be
too much longer I mean hopefully like I
said I've kind of got swamped with work
this past week so I didn't have a lot of
time to do yeah so I didn't have a lot
of time to do a much audio editing but
hopefully next week I'll kind of get all
that out of the way and maybe I can get
it done and get it uploaded by the end
of next week and so that should be
available do you know if you're pretty
soon what's I know if you've got any
reviews on the hard copies no not that I
saw no no but uh sold a lot of books
yeah yeah sold a lot of eBook sold a lot
of print books alright so and if you if
you haven't noticed like this episode I
decided to stop doing like the little
movie clips at the beginning and the
little music clips at the end it was
just too much of a pain it's like I
didn't want to run into copyright issues
things of that nature it's just like I
said it was just too much of a pain to
have to keep finding things like finding
theme songs and the amount of material
that we're putting out is expanding so
we have to maybe kind of hone things and
polish things down to where we still can
provide
a really cool show but it's not so
labor-intensive on Jenny because you
know she's doing all these shows and
then the books and then all the other
graphic design from the graphic design
business so yeah and she's making
packages it's weird you see in here
she's in here looking at boxes and it's
weird because it's like these are like
boxes that you see in a grocery store
and I'm like man you made that she's
like yeah well that's made it but she
did all the design yeah it's I sit there
and measure the boxes and be like okay
this little tab big boxes 28 centimeters
yessiree stores a shrimp
yeah when your girlfriend is I know it
is pretty weird right you just walk into
a store and be like hey hey yeah alright
so I'm also kind of like not I might
still do news stories at the beginning
like if there's something going on
that's like related to something we're
doing but I feel like that's something
that I probably am not gonna do every
time either because only this important
like I said only if it's important and
the shows have been running so long yeah
recently I mean [ __ ] our last show about
the harps and Belle Gunness was like an
hour 45 hours we can but it's very night
tonight yeah he's gotta help him set up
where actually he wants us to be there
around 7:00 okay yeah it's gonna take
about an hour to set up and get it ready
we're gonna socialize and then the doors
open today and then you know how it is
every time they come into town yeah I
know man yeah we're recording this on
Saturday and actually tonight we're
going down to downtown Orlando the iron
cow and we're gonna see which is like a
new venue they just opened up in the
milk district and it's awesome
we've been listening to it in the car
pretty much over and over and over again
it's so good it's not like a mixture of
sisters of Mercy's first and last and
always yeah and like with the epic
nature of kind of like the police
synchronicity album yeah it kind of you
know I mean not to me it's like an epic
goth album like that pretty neat and all
the songs are good there's really not
get stuck in your head yeah and then
they're not they're not poppy cheesy
repetitive songs they're just they're a
dick
really deep mana like them yeah yes it's
easily their best Salman realms are good
but I mean this at one there it's better
yeah we've just listened to it over and
over again like I just never get tired
by the flu all right so let's get on
with the Philadelphia Experiment now
this is something that you know a little
bit about you know this is a very very
popular story yeah
the let's do it the broad outline of the
Philadelphia Experiment some sources say
it was just one experiment some sources
say there were two of them but basically
the gist of it is that in the early days
of World War two that apparently the
Navy was experimenting on this
particular ship it was actually a
destroyer escort called the USS Eldridge
and they were experimenting with ways of
trying to make it invisible and either
on purpose or accidentally either ended
up sending it into another dimension
yeah teleporting it to Norfolk Virginia
or sending it back in time some say like
only about 10 minutes actually movie
yeah in the eighties they do and there
are also some like some of the more like
horrific things about it are that the
effects on the crew were said to be like
really really horrible they said you
know a lot of them went crazy yeah a lot
of the materialize they were like fused
with the hull of the ship
a couple accounts said some of the
people came like they Rhema T realized
inside out you know things have or you
know some they would blink in and out of
visibility like later on and stuff over
this whole thing up right you know and
make cover stories to explain why these
guys died you know right but it was
weird because when this these stories
first started to appear when I was a kid
they kind of sounded credible because
there were variations on the stories
yeah some investigators were saying no
they weren't trying to me
invisible to the naked eye they were
trying to make it invisible to radar
right and that they had some big cables
witnesses said there were big copper
cables wrapped around the hull this the
ship and that they had put some kind of
generator and a primitive computer in
their vacuum tubes to run a lot of
electric power down through here to get
this thing to maybe somehow deflect
radar waves right and that that
electromagnetic field may be really hurt
some guys that were on board and maybe
these stories about guys being fused
in between bulkheads it's an
exaggeration maybe they were just
somehow burned by radar waves because so
you can get killed by radar wave it's
like a microwave yeah real close if you
turn the combat radar on an f15 on while
it's on the ground
it'll evidently cook rabbits a couple
hundred feet out in front of the nose of
the the plane so maybe some
investigators were thinking that maybe
these stories were exaggerations of
something that really happened yeah
that's what I was thinking and I'm gonna
get into that a little bit later because
that that's pretty much my feeling as
well but apparently like I said there
were supposedly the main experiment that
they usually talk about to talk about
the Philadelphia Experiment supposedly
happened in late October of 1943 some
accounts also say that there was an
earlier one that happened in July and
that in that one it wasn't quite as
extreme but the ship kind of went
partially invisible and then there was
like a green fog and then like some of
the crew members were like nauseated
afterward and stuff like that but then
they didn't they didn't do anything
different they decided oh let's do
another experiment in the nated october
and then that was like the the bad one
where it went into a different dimension
or whatever yeah and see all these
little reports of green fog I remember
thinking at the time with the
investigators that we were dealing with
at the time and that maybe what they
were talking about is like an aurora
yeah one of the theories was is that you
make an electromagnetic field around
your ship you have the crew on it okay
then you hit the ship with a radar
are distant and see if it can deflect
you know what I mean or absorb those
radar waves yeah okay thereby not giving
a return signal okay with that that may
be plausible yeah and then part of the
test is is this say the next part of the
test is okay we're going to turn our
radar on and see if we can get a signal
off of the other ship so in other words
we're denying the enemy the ability to
see us but we can see them right let's
say they turned their radar on but the
radar waves aren't aren't absorbed by
the field instead they're somehow
bounced back into the ship which harm
the crew which maybe this is where these
stories are coming from guys that are
partially cooked or partially killed or
you know things like that
partially killed death is not you know
parsley wounded I don't know
I know because there were all these
stories about them being in in and
outside bulkheads and burned you know
and so in a way kind of sounded
plausible maybe they were doing an
experiment with radar invisibility and
people got hurt so that was the thinking
that was my thinking at the time I
really didn't buy into this
teleportation now I kind of have was
open-minded about this well maybe if
somehow you're messing with weird
electromagnetic frequencies maybe you
could maybe pull the rise the molecules
are the atoms inside of a body maybe you
would could slip through some matter a
little bit but but imperfectly because
matters mostly empty space anyway yeah
you know it's just I guess you could say
it's what is it the nuclear weak force I
think that that prevents matter from
going inter penetrating from other
matter something like that I don't
remember you know I'm not a nuclear
physicist but who knows maybe some when
you're a kid you're thinking maybe some
electromagnetic field maybe could you
know polarized matter yeah yeah the
problem that with the Philadelphia
Experiment
though and this is the kind of thing
like I said I'm the skeptic skeptic it's
like you know pretty much
I'm not buying most [ __ ] that I hear and
the thing that when you hear a story
like this that sounds this implausible
the first thing you have to ask yourself
is where does this story originate
yeah where did this story originate
where is the source so as it happened it
did not originate in 1943 it actually
originated in 1955 let's go back to 1955
there's this fella he's named Morris K
Jessup he's actually he's a writer he
he's an auto part salesman by trade but
he is also an amateur astronomer who's
interested in UFOs in 1955 he publishes
a book called the case for the UFO and
he's kind of talking about I don't think
he's talking about them really exists
but he's talking but if they existed
these are some maybe some of the
propulsion systems they would use and
things of that nature now after this
book comes out Jessup gets starts
getting a series of letters from this
other fella who is alternately named a
Carlos a yin day or Allende or Carl
Allen and he's sending him all these
letters and in these letters that this
random person sent to Morris K Jessup
who had written a book about UFOs this
is where he first starts talking about
the Philadelphia Experiment nobody never
mentioned it before this this was just a
guy who was writing letters to this
person who said I was on he didn't say
that he was on the USS eldridge which
was the ship that supposedly disappeared
he said I was on a merchant ship that
was in the same dock in Philadelphia and
I saw these things happen so that's
pretty much this is where the story
originates from these letters from this
person okay so basically what you have
is you have an amateur UFO writer one of
his fans tells him this story yes okay
this is where this is the first this is
a first recorded incident incidents of
the
the Philadelphia sir here is that if
this were to happen today it would
happen online it would be somebody
making a video like us and then somebody
in the comment section coming in telling
you a story but because this is all back
in print media is in a way it kind of
had some kind of weight to it yeah more
weight to information back then because
there was less of it yeah yeah so
basically in the letter like I said this
Carl Allen or Carlos Allende person he
says you know I saw this all of this
happened with the USS Eldridge he's like
they were doing experiments it was
rendered invisible it was teleported to
New York was the first thing he said he
also said that it went to another
dimension and that there were aliens
there okay and he also said the whole
thing about the guys being fused with
the ship's hull now Morris cage s up to
his credit he gets these letters he
reads them he's like this dude is crazy
because how would he know and he just
ignored it how would he know the ship
disappeared and went to New York and
came back when he was just witnessing it
from another ship right he wouldn't be
he wouldn't have been in on the
experiment right exactly
so he would just see it disappear and
then it come back right how would he
know that it went to New York that's
secrecy that's what that's the one thing
that always bothered me but how did you
know that it went to another dimension
and there were aliens there how would
you know that right
but that but apparently he said he knew
and he wrote these letters so this guy
now Jessup was like okay whatever he
just thought he was a nut then he kind
of forgets about it until about two
years later one and a half two years
later in 1957 worst jess at the UFO book
guy he gets contacted by the Office of
Naval Research in Washington DC and this
office said you know somebody sent us a
package with your book in it and it was
all that I don't think it had a return
address or anything like that but it's
just said Happy Easter
somebody had sent them a copy of Morris
K Jessops book but they had annotated
like all of this stuff in the margins
now
these annotations were supposedly three
different people discussing things that
were in this book it was three different
colors of pink ink and it was just that
like neat
the people were named really like one of
them I think was called Jimmy the other
two people didn't have names this like I
said is supposedly three different
people discussing all of the stuff that
Jessup was talking about in this book
and it was like really in-depth so
the Office of Naval Research the onr
they're like okay well here's Jimmy
here's mr. a and here's mr. B but they
contacted Morris just days did you know
who this person is like why did would
they send us your book and stuff like
that but apparently they were interested
enough in what the annotation said that
they actually paid for like a small run
of a hundred books of Morris Jessup's
book published with all the annotations
in it right it was just like a you know
a limited print run who paid for this
yeah the Office of Naval Research paid
for it just just like a hundred okay
stop one second so the Navy gets this
book yeah from this UFO writer somebody
scribbled a bunch of fanfiction in the
margins yeah that was so compelling that
the Navy wanted more copies of it yeah
I'm not really sure why like maybe they
did think there was because like I said
Morse Jessup's book was not about the
Philadelphia Experiment it was about
alien propulsion systems so and a lot of
the annotations were like commenting on
that and maybe the Navy thought some of
the stuff sounded plausible enough that
they thought it was interesting enough
to just pay for like a small run of it
that's weird
yeah so this is called the Barrow
annotations this book now when they
contacted Jessup he's like looking at
the at the annotations and he says okay
the handwriting the misspellings the
weird like capitalization and stuff he's
like that looks just like the letters
that this Carl Allen person sent to me
and the Navy kind of looked into it too
and he said yeah I think this is the
same person writing with three different
pens pretending to be three different
people and obviously this person has
some problems although it sounds like
he'd have been an awesome fiction writer
he may have been sure so a couple years
later apparently Jessup was trying to
publish more books but wasn't really
successful and he ended up committing
suicide after
some kind of like personal that's right
he ran the damn exact exhaust pipe into
his car yeah yeah so put it put it put a
hose around the tailpipe and ran it in
through the window and yeah yeah creepy
and then it kind of adds some gravitas
to the story it makes you makes you
think that maybe he was on to something
and not I mean they killed him or
silenced him for it yeah see that's
always what they're that's what they're
gonna say but I see what they're really
what it was his failed rider huh had had
other problems and yeah they said he had
some personal problems as well so I'm I
don't know if his wife left him or
something like that but yeah so a lot of
things and he wasn't able to publish any
more books I guess he kept getting
rejected and stuff so um so that's how
that went now then for a while that was
in 1959 when he died then there wasn't
really any more popularization of the
story until about 1963 and at this point
there was a book published that was
called invisible horizons true mysteries
of the sea and the guy that wrote the
book was named Vincent Gatos and he
actually had read the Vero annotated
version of Morris Jessup's book so he
added the Philadelphia Experiment to his
book you know it was like a compilation
of like weird and C stories and you know
creepy unexplained things and stuff so
he repeated it in there as though it was
a real event and then in 1978 two guys
named George Simpson and Neil burger
they actually wrote a novel called thin
air that was based on the Philadelphia
Experiment it was a novel it was a
fiction but the problem being is that
the year after that novel came out then
these two guys named Charles Berlitz and
William Moore the first of which he was
like a Bermuda Triangle guy and the
second guy was like a UFO shit-shit was
on TV a lot yeah yeah he's very well
known this was 1979 yeah
so they actually collaborated on a book
that was called the Philadelphia
Experiment project invisibility in which
they pretty much they ripped off large
portions of thin air the fictional novel
that was based on that was based on the
very notations and then they also added
a bunch of stuff of their own so that's
when the Philadelphia Experiment really
kind of came into the public
consciousness at you know when it when
there was his book that came out about
it like I said where they had ripped off
like a lot of stuff that was out of a
novel and then in 1984 that book was
made into a movie which was called this
the Philadelphia Experiment it didn't do
all that well in the theaters yeah it
was on HBO I was on cable lying r8t yeah
yeah it was on Mystery Science Theater
actually like on there back to back yeah
yeah so that so the movie actually kind
of helped to cement you know the the
details of it in the public
consciousness now this this movie is
actually gonna serve as the bridge
between the Philadelphia Experiment and
the Montauk Project which you're gonna
talk about in the second half but I'll
get into that a little bit later so but
that that movie was kind of like the
turning point for that so according to
most sources the Philadelphia Experiment
of what they were trying to do with it
allegedly was that it was based on some
aspect of Albert Einstein's unified
field theory you know that they were
trying to get like large electrical
generators that would make light white
light waves go around an object like to
render it invisible you know there were
other things about it as well but the
mostly most of the sources say that even
though the Navy of course has denied
that it did this experiment ever
happened but most of the later
researchers come in and say the USS
eldridge which was the you know the
destroyer you know the the ship that
goes along with the destroyer wasn't an
actual destroyer but it had the
equipment put on it at the Philadelphia
Naval Shipyard and then there was
supposedly a first test of it in summer
of 1943 this was the time when the ship
supposedly went mostly invisible and
there was like a green fog and then you
know it then it popped back into
existence and like the crew were all
sick and everything like that then
evidently the equipment was not
recalibrated but then they did another
test in October and that was when you
get the thing where it's supposedly
teleported and all this other kind of
stuff like people going crazy infusing
the bulkheads and all this others so
where they get now like I said that all
of this information and many many
skeptics have pointed out all of the
details about the Philadelphia
Experiment essentially all come from
these letters from this Carl Allen
person okay who sent them to more so
that is the first record of it there's
no records of it anywhere they always go
back to refer to those yeah and most of
the books that were written about it
later on are basically just taking stuff
either from the movie or from the
original letters you know that were
published alongside the the Jessup UFO
book so they're all pretty much just
repeating from the same source again and
again rather than like trying to
substantiate you know this same source
not only just talking about
teleportation and this what we call the
authority of experiment he's also
writing stuff about UFO propulsion and
sending it to the to the Air Force of
all places I mean yeah well the book was
about UFO propulsion yeah and then he's
annotating again why would he send that
to the Air Force was there anything to
the Navy has she been to the Navy
why would he send that to the Navy I
suspect that this Carl Allen person was
a schizophrenic okay cuz why would he
think the Navy would be interested in
that that's the weird thing
yeah I'm not entirely sure um
not understand maybe sense sending it to
the Air Force I haven't read what he
read
yeah was he trying to perpetrate a hoax
or was it we're gonna have to find it
just I just kind of feel like I don't
know if he was necessarily trying to
perpetrate a hoax on purpose
but I think that they don't know a lot
about him but if he is the person that
they think that it is he did have some
mental issues and it might be a case
where like I said this is a very common
thing in schizophrenic swear they're
they're like very very intelligent but
they come up with these like really
grandiose um you know kind of schemes or
like conspiracies and things and I feel
like that's what he was doing so I don't
think that he was trying to perpetrate a
hoax necessarily um I just think that he
may be really did believe that stuff and
he may be just trying to get involved
trying to be involved in the brain I
just look I like it oh and I'm gonna put
my name here you go maybe check this out
yes that superficial it might have been
that like he might have been like yeah I
know all about this stuff and I you know
I I saw things ship my ship go into
another dimension and there was aliens
there and all the same to his favorite
writer yeah I feel like that might have
been as simple as it was right now is
there any basis in fact for the
Philadelphia Experiment now some people
said that there might be now obviously
the the [ __ ] that happened you know one
was fused to the bulkhead it's fine no
as far as is known none of the crew of
the USS eldridge at least the ones that
are surviving that they've talked to
have said that anything unusual was
going on at all so you know is where the
Philadelphia Experiment starts to break
down if you ask me yeah it's the crew
and the ship you know where the ship is
at any time you know where the crew are
at any one time in you know that's like
it'd be like somebody coming in line
about what the first in the 506 was
doing back in 1990 yeah I was there yeah
well so we're thousands of other guys
you couldn't say that we were talking to
aliens in 1990 on the DMZ
you couldn't say that because there were
too many living witnesses well you could
say that they say but guys would come
right but then conspiracy theorists
would say oh well they told you to jump
or they brainwashed jacket which is
essentially exactly what who believed
that the Philadelphia Experiment really
happened right that's what they say
about all the crew members of the ask
better because crew members like really
there was nothing like that going on in
the ship there's nothing weird you know
nothing strange going on at all I would
think that if there was an
the experiment there had been physical
evidence left behind yeah well here's
the thing but number one if the first
experiment which supposedly happened in
July of 1943 with the green fog and
everything the action the USS Eldridge
wasn't actually commissioned until late
August of 1943 and it was actually in
New York provably until September of
that year so so that day and they're
like even at the time when the
Philadelphia Experiment was supposed to
have taken place in late October 1943
according to the USS Eldridge ship logs
they were actually in the Bahamas they
were not in Philadelphia at that time
right so that's against it so that's one
thing that's against another thing
that's against it let's say they came up
with some kind of technology that could
make something disappear or even cause a
green fog or cause radar into visibility
or caused interpenetration of matter
even if guys got killed they wouldn't
stop experimenting with it they'd
continue yeah they've continued working
with that yeah well by now it would be a
known technology yeah you would think
yeah but see the thing is so what a lot
of later researchers have said and what
a lot of people who were actually on the
crew of the USS Eldridge have said
they're like maybe what happened they're
like okay so you know the USS Eldridge
was in Philadelphia there was another
ship there also and there was a bunch of
merchant ships and stuff too so he's
like now one thing that we did do during
World War two and a lot of other ships
did this also was like you were
mentioning earlier is called D gowing or
D perming where you would take like big
cables like you said you kind of wrap
them around the hull you shoot like high
voltage currents through it and it
doesn't make the ship invisible like to
the naked eye it makes it invisible to
magnetic minds and magnetic torpedoes
which was a big problem during World War
two because the Germans well thought the
u-boats like coming up the East Coast
and they were trying to like get supply
ships and stuff like that so they were
trying to make the ships they were
trying to like mess up the magnetic
signature so that mines and torpedoes
wouldn't hit them so they're like if
somebody on a merchant ship that didn't
know anything about that heard like
Freeman talking about we're gonna make
the ship invisible maybe they thought
BurgerTime felt like actual invisible
rather than invisible to minds I don't
have any naval experience or anything
but I also thought that Dee gowing had
something to do with demagnetizing
the ship's hull so your compasses would
read accurately oh I don't know I think
that might have been part of it also but
you know maybe I'm wrong
yeah because they use magnetic compass
back then and you know if you have an
Allsteel structure it's possible that
you might have certain things kind of
magnetized over time right yeah and it
might affect it might affect the compass
just slightly and when you if you're
dealing with big distances just a half a
mil of deviation it ends up being a lot
if you're gonna travel 500 mile leg to a
trip you know what I mean yeah it might
put you off course yeah
so I think maybe we might have some
seamen in there it might know about it
but I think the gals and also had to do
with keeping your compasses regulated
basically yeah
there was also another experiment that
was done on a different destroyer which
was called the USS Timmerman now they
had a generator on there that actually
produced some like light Coronas no one
on the crew was injured or anything like
that but they said so that might have
had something to do with it also the
area of Philadelphia where this
particular ships were docked where the
supposed experiment took place there's a
lot of st. Elmo's fire in the area so
like let you know like Coronas in the
sky and stuff like that so that could
have added to the confusion as well
there's law so you'll be added to the
inspiration yeah except that might have
been all this stuff and said you know
what imagine if this was happening
imagine if that happened right and then
it just becomes part of his you know
science fiction fantasy yeah really I
kind of think that the guy who wrote
that didn't knew that didn't happen I
think it was fanfiction yeah like I said
it's completely possible they have
established they think that this Carlos
a yin day or a lend a person was
actually a guy who was just named Carl
Allen he lived in Kensington Kensington
Pennsylvania and he did have mint
illness issues according to this family
so if this was indeed the guy that had
started the whole thing and wrote the
letters that started the story about the
Philadelphia Experiment then he might
have been like you said he might have
been really believed it or he might have
just conflated all these things in his
head and wrote this crazy
I tend I tend to think that what it was
is that that was his favorite author and
he liked what the author wrote yeah and
he says I can do that I here's another
subject I think it was more like fan
fiction yeah how much I bet that he only
half believed what he was reading about
the UFOs yeah though you're gonna tell
me a tall tale I'm gonna tell you the
tall tale yeah yeah I mean I can do that
and then he that's a cool story that's
stuck yeah and I'm not saying that he
might have been he might very well have
been on a merchant ship yeah I saw the
USS Eldridge thing and saw the USS
angstrom which was the other thing and
then you know maybe at the time he was
one yeah time travel you know or
something because something else he said
a couple other things he said did have
some kind of parallels in reality you
know one of the things he said was that
the ship teleported right now one of the
crew members of the Eldridge or of the
Engstrom which was the other ship that
was docked there next to next to it he
said okay well if you want to say that
the ship teleported from Philadelphia to
Norfolk Virginia which is they usually
say he's like here's how that could have
been misinterpreted he's like okay now a
merchant ship would have had to go
around the outside of the East Coast if
you're going from Philadelphia to
Norfolk he said it took about two days
he's like however the Navy was allowed
to use like Chesapeake Bay and there's
like a canal like inland now no one
really knew about it they were trying to
keep it on the down-low because they
didn't want the Germans to find out
about it but that was how they were
safely transporting ships they were
keeping them inland and only the Navy
could use those canals so they're like
so the route from Philadelphia to
Norfolk only took six hours rather than
two days so he's like so if someone on a
merchant ship was like oh suddenly
they're in Norfolk only a couple hours
later how the [ __ ] did that happen they
must have teleported so he's like so
that might have been the germ of that
story there was also a storage guys
noticing that the military ships were
getting there we're getting there faster
which is so they must be experimenting
to tell
this is that that's that might be why
they said because most people that were
on merchant ships and stuff wouldn't
have known you know that the Navy was
taking these inland canals like to avoid
you know being seen and whatnot
there was also stories about like I said
that some of the crew members afterward
this is a very famous story had been in
a bar and they had been like flickering
like in and out of like invisibility
where they were fightin and stuff okay
well one of the guys who was there he
said there was actually a bar fight that
night it was like two different guys
from two to four chips and they were
talking [ __ ] the other ones they start
to fight like you do and he's like he's
like I'm he's like I'm one of the guys
that usually in in the stories is said
to have disappeared he's like all that
happened was that me and this in my
buddy were underage and we weren't
really supposed to be drinking and so
when this fight broke out like all this
trouble started a couple of the bar
maids were like come get out the back
like so you don't get caught because
you're underage so we just kind of
skedaddled and went back to the ship
with that and telling anyone where we
were going and then the barmaids really
pointed so I don't know we didn't see
him so they're like that's why that
might be why like people like all the
guys just disappeared one day they're
maybe see I don't know he might have
been because he did seem to know details
about this like I said he never claimed
to be on the I don't think he ever
claimed to be in the Navy or on one of
the ships that was a supposedly affected
or he was supposedly on a merchant ship
that was docked in the same way could
have been know that he heard about that
fight or that he heard about it from
someone that he knew sure he didn't
necessarily have to be there because
they were normally fighting in those
bars anyway he just got lucky
he got lucky he got lucky that two guys
there that night were like yeah we
totally disappeared because we were
underage a warrant supposed to be
drinking in there so the bar mates like
snuck us out the back different places
there are places in Korea I'm gonna play
a famous place in Korea down Seoul it
still exists it's called hooker hill
yeah I don't know if they're still
hookers on it but it you can say yeah it
was a fighting hooker yeah well of
course there's a fight hooker hell there
was a fight in every bar on hooker army
vs. army yeah guys from different army
you
fighting each other yeah and nobody
really got seriously hurt that seems to
be the case and in this thing but see so
like I said there are actually real life
you know nothing exciting it's like no
we were just degaussing the ship or it
was just saying almost fire or there was
like a light corona from a generator you
know these guys were in a bar and they
just snuck out the back because they
weren't supposed to be there you know
stuff like that you know inland canals
like we the Navy gets there like way
quicker than the merchant ships could so
they must be teleporting so there's like
a realistic you know kind of component
of where these where the story could
have come from and then evidently this
Carl Allen either saw it or heard about
it from somebody he knew and just
decided he was going to confabulate the
[ __ ] out of it and say yeah the ship
disappeared went back in time there was
a linson that he added all this stuff to
it and over the years the story kept
getting picked up and repeated you know
in both fiction and nonfiction venues
and I think it just kind of it's it kind
of reminds me of the SS Ourang Medan
that ship that supposedly had the frozen
people on it and all those other kind of
stuff where it's basically it was first
published as a fictional story like a
creepy story and then it just kept
getting republished and reponse it's now
everybody thinks it really happened
except it never did it was first
published as a fictional story and I
think the same thing weren't we talking
about when we did that toad-in-the-hole
show about the pterodactyl and
everything again that was something that
was it was first published as a parody
or like a funny story and then it just
kept subsequently getting more right
like people started publishing it in
books on the paranormal and something
adding more details so it's all like a
game of telephone and I think that's
essentially what happened here like I
said people that believe it really
happened you know nothing you say like
all the crew members that say no I was
there nothing really happened you know
the conspiracy theorists are gonna be
like oh well that's what they told you
to say or they brainwash you or whatever
and we'll get into that a little bit
with the Montauk Project team because
there's a lot of brainwashing going on
in that one evidently too but um so I
know it's funny that you
over there brainwash you told you knew
we're nowhere else that happened that
damn UFO pet Rendlesham forest yes of
the Rendlesham forest witnesses don't
quite line up with the more reputable
witnesses and his story is is that the
people who saw what he saw all got
drugged and brainwashed and debriefed
and you know and we're made to kind of
forget it they're not talking yeah it's
I'm other guys that were there says man
what are you talking about
yeah I'm just like wait we'll probably
do a whole show in Rendlesham forest cuz
I want to do Renison forest and really
that's been requested I thought there
were some good witnesses to that but
really what it do it mounts to his
lights in the sky and some light
something giving off light and look like
there was dripping sparks going across
the field out in the trees what it is
and they'll be knows but it's pretty
interesting I had at least some new
stuff that surfaced about radar
signatures get the radar tower got but I
don't know then there's other guys that
come up with number codes and their
heads that they wrote down back then and
oh look I still have it after all these
years fishy well and the problem too is
that and and like I said this is why and
I know I sound like a like a big
skeptical [ __ ] it's like I don't I
can't just rely on people's memories or
people's stories about something because
memory is not reliable it's just not no
one's inaudible people tell stories yeah
the best part of the story is the guys
that walked up on the little triangular
craft not everyone there agrees to have
seen that craft which that's kind of
[ __ ] you would think that there's a
group of five guys you would think that
all five of them would see that yeah not
like two or three
you know manages I mean seriously though
it just just from a personal point of
view and I like I said I'm a very
skeptical person I'm a rather reasonable
person I'm not like subject to like
flights of fancy or anything like that
but even I have had trouble like
sometimes I'll have dreams that are
specifically that are pretty like
realistic and then after a week or two
goes by I can't remember if it really
happened or if I dreamed it or because
like sometimes I'll dream something and
then all dreams that I'll tell you and
then I can't
remember if I actually told you in real
life or if I dreamed it so even then
it's like memories are really not
reliable so if you're just going by one
person's story yeah it's like you
remember something for childhood you
remember what it looks like and
everything and then you come across that
item again 30 40 and it's nothing like
that's what that was that's all it was
yeah you know the same things happen
like when we've been revisiting like
movies that we haven't seen since we
were kids and a lot of times they're way
different than I remembered something
it's not but usually they are like I
just remembered I just I just mentioned
hangar 18 yeah I loved that as a kid
these two show it on HBO all the time I
saw recently it's unwatchable and it
really it's unwatchable it's like it's
it was like a made-for-tv movie that got
rejected for television that's how bad
it was we didn't want to give it to
cable though watch it I remember being
awesome like I said it was it was on
Mystery Science data because it was like
in the public domain or something
terrible yeah it really I don't I have a
hard time watching it even on mysteries
well you know like like I said you're
really not even the same person that you
were in that age was you know
considering all the cell cell
destruction and like remaking it yes so
you're like not even really the same
organism pretty much yeah but like I
said even your memories memories are
[ __ ] they just they're just really not
good I don't remember a lot of stuff
from my childhood at all but anyway so
let's take a break right now when we
come back we're going to talk about a
related supposed government project it
was supposedly covered up that happened
40 years later called the Montauk
Project lesser known but kind of ties in
with the whole Philadelphia Experiment
thing so we will talk about that when we
get back we will be back in just a
couple minutes okay everybody
ginnis got some new shirt designs up
four of them really good ones to Atlanta
Ripper who put Bella in the which out
the HH Holmes murder castle and of
course demon child because man said he
could these are updated designs
I think they look really cool Jenny did
a great job autumn where they found
making Jenny
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out right yeah
yeah really good they're very high
quality shirts Jenny and I we're sure
our own shirts at certain times when
we're trying to put spotlight on
ourselves and you can put a spotlight on
yourselves if you go ahead and pick up
on these shirts today you guys are gonna
love them links in the description WWL
calm at 13 o'clock yeah so go check out
our store at wwl calm / 13 o'clock we
got these four cool new t-shirt designs
plus all our old ones if you'd rather
get one at all ones but these ones are
awesome and you should check them out
they're also available in women's cut
and they look really cute JD's got some
so thank you go check them out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I think that's why there is so
significant because we are willing to
put pen to paper and conclude at the end
of the day at this house is very much
haunted and will continue to be odds of
a long time okay we're back now on this
segment of the show we're going to talk
about an interrelated conspiracy theory
series of experiments known as the
Montauk Project this is considerably
less well known I feel like than the
Philadelphia Experiment yeah it's
probably better known nowadays because I
don't know if most of our listeners are
aware but the very popular Netflix
series stranger things was actually
loosely based on the Montauk Project and
in fact when the deafer Brothers first
pitched it to Netflix this series was
actually titled Montauk and was set on
Montauk Long Island where these
experiments allegedly took place only
later on was the title changed and they
changed the setting to Indiana but yeah
so this is kind of much like on stranger
things this has to do with a series of
experiments on people particularly
children and it's supposedly looking
into doing time-travel opening
interdimensional rift psychological
warfare all kind of thing okay so yeah
so what year are we talking about when
did this this was the early 1980s that
it first got heard about although as I
said there there have been some tiebacks
with the Philadelphia Experiment so
according to the people who came up with
this stuff apparently they've been
ongoing since the Philadelphia
Experiment
do you think maybe this is where maybe
Stephen King got his idea for the mist
the Montauk um it's possible it's not
real similar I'm Lionism
okay yeah now again you have to ask
yourself you know yes there is a
decommissioned Air Force Base on Montauk
Long Island it is still there there's a
big radar dish they don't do anything
there now apparently but I guess there
like some stories circulating there was
like some secret military experiments
like going on - they're like you know
what I mean you can still go to the site
you're not really supposed to crawl
around in there but you can still see it
there's still some stuff there now again
just as in the Philadelphia Experiment
where does this story come from
initially now whereas the Philadelphia
Experiment came from letters sent to a
guy who wrote a book about UFO
propulsion this evidently came from one
guys supposedly recovered memories of
being a subject of this particular
series of experiments okay this guy's
name was Preston Nichols and evidently
he just recovered some memories that he
had been subjected to these experiments
like he'd been abducted and that he was
subjected to all these really weird
experiments where they were trying to do
like I said they were trying to do like
teleportation telepathy psychological
warfare that type of thing so and he
starts writing a bunch of books about
this alleged series of experiments him
in this guy named Peter moon they write
a series of books called the Montauk
Project series now in these books
interestingly they don't come out and
say that they're fiction and they don't
come out and say that they're nonfiction
like the little notes at the end use
phrases like soft facts you know you can
read it as fiction or nonfiction it's
still a good story you know that says
that kind of stuff
so this is like a whole series of books
about this and he's started to come out
in about the early 80s now how this ties
in with the Philadelphia Experiment see
so this this guy this Nichols person is
saying yes I was subjected to all these
and I was brainwashed and I forgot about
it but now I remember some writing this
series of books about it so in 1988 this
other guy named Al Bielek I guess is how
you pronounce his name he was 57 years
old at the time
he watched the movie the Philadelphia
Experiment and it supposedly triggered
his own repressed memory okay of how he
was involved in the Philadelphia
Experiment now this is very
convoluted so excuse me if I get the
details kind of wrong I kept to go by
skeptical position bracing myself for
this yes
so this Albee lek person if I'm
pronouncing RB liqueur how every noun
sit yes so he's like okay the the movie
made him remembers like yes the
Philadelphia Experiment is real and I
was on the ship when that happened I was
involved in it he says that Nikola Tesla
was there and that he figured out how to
make the Eldridge invisible okay but
while he was doing that he sort of oopsy
opened up a wormhole into the future
that sucked the Eldridge in for a brief
time now Al Bielek also claims that he's
like Oh Al Bielek isn't actually my name
my real name is Edward Cameron and they
actually gave me a new identity after
all this happened like I said this is
very convoluted so try to see so here's
the time wormhole so this al Bielek
person who says back then when he was on
the ship he was actually named Edward
Cameron and he also had a brother named
Duncan Cameron and they were on the
Eldridge when the ship got sucked
through the wormhole and they jumped out
on Montauk in 1983 the military saw this
happen and sent them back through the
wormhole so that they could destroy the
ship that was on the Eldridge that had
accidentally opened this time portal I
love the movie 1983 yes he said that's
the movie
that's what conveniently he watched the
movies like that's exactly what happened
I kind of feel like some people have
trouble separating movies from I'm just
saying
well some movies are inspired by reality
they are some movies are someone tried
to express something that's real like
like in James Bond
yeah but it didn't literally happen that
way yeah yeah
so another thing that yeah this albick
person claimed he said that he'd had his
memory wiped and that they had given him
this new albick identity because that
wasn't really his name he also said that
he'd been de-aged or they'd mess with
his aging process which would explain
how he could be a certain agent
everything now he also said that his
brother Duncan now this is kind of weird
he said that he okay
Edward in 1963 had told his dad you and
my mom need to have another kid because
Duncan who was his brother back on the
USS Eldridge in the forties needed a
portal like he needed he called it a
walk-in soul like he needed another
brother like for Duncan to come into and
be that person like going forward okay
so I'm I'm just telling I'm not I'm not
no more my yeah okay I'm just telling
you so at this point this is very much
like something from another era yes so
at this stage Preston Nichols who had
written the book about the Montauk
Project experiments and this Al Bielek
person who said yeah it totally happened
and it was related to the Philadelphia
Experiment it was a time where wormhole
from 1943 to 1983 and we were trying to
close it and all this other kind of
stuff so then they kind of got together
and started talking about all the
experiments now one of the main things
and like I said this is where stranger
things got a lot of the ideas about
about 11 the psycho girl where she could
open up with like a rift in in
time-space and you know brought a
monster through there which they called
the Deming organ on the show but this
that's something that that they kind of
got from this so apparently one of the
experiments that they were doing they
were doing like remote viewing [ __ ] it's
kind of stuff to you but they had this
one thing that was called the Montauk
chair and it was apparently this chair
that amplified psychic ability I guess
so al Bielek said that his brother
duncan was like the the best psychic and
he was like a kid at the time I guess I
don't really know how the whole
timeline works out because like I said
they're going back and forth in
wormholes and all this guy stuff so I
don't know so yes reality was this
exciting I mean I [ __ ] saw ultra guys
phenomena yeah I had a near-death
experience from a motorcycle accident I
had an OBE yeah but it wasn't this
exciting that's nothing it's not that
exciting really yeah it is kind of
ashamed where I'm jumping through
wormholes and portals and telling my
parents to have more children and all
this kind and the government's involved
and now I wish there are there are
paranormal things that happen I've seen
them but they're just not this they're
not this interest they're not this
flashy I feel they're not this flashing
they don't involve government agencies
and they don't involve this doesn't
happen that way yeah doesn't happen that
way it's usually something that's in a
weird way of a mundane situation you
know yeah we're unusual [ __ ] happens in
the mundane said well this is I've seen
it yeah it's be like we were out there
you know and the TV remote and weird
doorbells ringing it's it's weird you
can't point it but it's not it's not
that like a movies not like a movie
where there's a big plot to it right
you're not I mean if there's a meaning
to it it doesn't well I'm like I said we
mentioned on I think we mentioned on our
on our little matinee video when we were
talking about I think we were talking
about venom yeah and we were talking
about poltergeist activities it's
actually kind of started up a little bit
again mostly it's little [ __ ] the TV
keeps turning it so there's an article
of clothing that is still missing
yes I had an article of clothing that
disappeared into thin air
[Laughter]
and I can't figure out where it went to
I don't I don't see how it could have
gone that far I mean you know I don't
know
[Laughter]
[ __ ] rift in the long t-shirt slash
dress yeah what's like a little like a
night dress yeah
it's missing I have no idea we're gonna
bond for over a week and that yeah the
cat couldn't have taken that anywhere it
was too big yeah and we would have found
it and she does that she gets bored of
dragging things around like she'll drag
things around for a little while but
usually she only drags my few feet never
saw it again where she puts it under the
bed she puts everything under the bed
but it's not under there so I didn't
turn it off and on again
yeah that's pretty creepy I mean it's
not it's but I don't know it's just
creepy you just hadn't done it in over a
year
yeah it's not the same TV and it's not
the same cable service that we had when
we used to when it used to be yeah so I
don't know it's it's nothing like you
know we're not seeing like spectres or
anything like that
it's just weird creepy [ __ ] like that it
has to do with emotional state yeah been
working out a lot maybe that has
something do that yeah yeah I don't know
but yeah so okay so one of the
experiments that they were supposedly
doing in this Montauk chair that Duncan
was doing cuz like I said he was
supposedly like the biggest psychic and
this this whole thing was predicated
upon like I said much like in stranger
things where they're abducting children
and doing all these experiments on him
so that like you know they're doing it
against their will essentially it's what
they're claiming so evidently Duncan
would sit in the montauk chair and they
would do this experiment which is called
the seeing-eye which again very much
like some stuff they were doing with 11
on stranger things where they would give
him an object that belonged to somebody
and then he could see out of that
person's eyes and it worked on anybody
they said he could so it's essentially
like remote viewing so there was kind of
that experiment to this Bielek and the
other guy nickels are claiming that
there's like a whole bunch of different
subjects that they call the Montauk boys
that they got abducted from their homes
and taken to the to camp hero out on
Montauk Long Island where they were
doing all these experiments on them like
in like underground bunkers and [ __ ]
like that they also said that they could
time travel that they could travel to
Mars because you know it's just too much
for me
yeah it's a it's like if you're gonna
come up just pro tip if you're gonna
come up with a story like this it just
can't be like hold it down several
notches what Tony it's fanfiction is
what it is and I guarantee you this kind
of goes along the way and some people
might get mad at me philip corso all
right Phil course oh he was a anyway
just the more a guy tells stories a lot
of when he's bullshitting the bigger
that story gets with time because he
starts to accrue all these fans so the
fans keep pressuring him building or
going on more so it starts to go from
yeah alien technology there was a UFO oh
we have the UFO oh we can build the UFO
and you know what we can also build time
machines I saw a time machine I went
through the time machine it just starts
to grow you know and the truth stays
about the same okay which I can say one
thing about the Rendlesham forest
incident that story did grow but it took
a long time for it to grow and only
certain guys their stories grew you know
I think his name is Holt the colonel
whole his story remained consistent and
I I think he you think he's a good man
and he's he's saying what he saw saw
lights in this guide something look like
a I trippin molten stuff but you have
some guys it just you know straight up
they're gonna [ __ ] tell a big swell
every time you see them tell it they had
more and more detail now I can go back
to another one that to me just sounds
strangely true that old drunken
hillbilly they could put a camera up to
his eye and oh right yeah I can't really
he could do that for a certain period of
time then it went away then he had a big
reunion as an old man with the original
guy and they trying to do it and
couldn't do it yeah it stands to reason
that if the guy was a fake all right he
would have waited the 50 years or the 40
years right and come back and done it
yeah yeah no he couldn't do it I still
got it can do it he drank and everything
he had to be drunk to do it and that's a
weird case yeah some people say that
maybe he was slipping something with a
little tube that's usually how that
trick is done but Sir I didn't spoil it
for some of those photos were photos of
things that actually existed but they
were slightly different yeah I like the
struts on the airplane wings or
backwards things like that one of them
was a caveman that came from the Museum
of Natural History you know they took a
picture you probably wouldn't be able to
get away with that now because you can
just do like google search like you
could find every single photo you like
here they never caught him yeah they
never caught him anyway it was why what
do you think you think it was a fake yes
you think was yeah yeah yep all right so
here's he call it a knock you later
some weird [ __ ] like a weird sex toy
later it's like a dildo with Lana Nate
was like a camera man didn't even like
but I forgot what it was that was a
crazy dude I was I was buying it and
then he did it to the video camp to the
TV camera to revisit it yeah I feel like
yeah we see like a lot of stuff like I
said I used to read all those like
paranormal like unsolved mystery type
books and stuff and I'm like ooh weird
but then like if you reveal later
you're either like yeah that's not how
it really happened like how they wrote
in that book or it's not how you
remember there wasn't it weird as you
remember it or whatever
okay so field still blows me away though
yeah and field in this house is haunted
that that book yeah because I was just
like mine yeah yeah now some of it's
[ __ ] I think some of the witnesses
exaggerated what they saw but in general
that was a real case oh she's just
saying just to tell just book that book
most of that really happened now you
know I can't really you know the
crossing guard that saw her that said
she saw Janet floating up through the
window how could you you know it's just
one witness saw that you know maybe that
didn't happen but in general I think the
stuff that Maurice
and guy Lyon Playfair what they saw I
believe that they they were truthful
because it matched up with the kind of
phenomena I saw yeah yeah so the whole
thing like I said a lot of the stuff
that was concerned around the montauk
chair now according to nichols
who said that he was there and he worked
on some of these pressure he was
experimented on he said at one point
they turned on the montauk chair and
then they were supposed to leave it
running until August 12th 1983 at which
point the the wormhole opened like back
to 1943 when the Philadelphia Experiment
happened and that was when Al Bielek
claimed that him and his brother like
came through there were normal and stuff
like that so in apparently the
Philadelphia Experiment the Montauk
chair it was like a time portal and it
had like the energy like the generator
at both ends so you could like go back
and forth blah blah blah now in this
[ __ ] like this actually happened in real
life that's never never you're tying in
two and three different Paranal famous
paranormal cases yeah find them all
together that's what I mean and it seems
really interesting if how shaky the
Philadelphia Experiment story actually
is yeah I think maybe that was inspired
by something that a crazy guy saw
probably do gowing you know but I don't
think that it happened now yeah I mean I
feel like a lot of these stories were
kind of like just it was just one crazy
dude like saying something or
misinterpreting something or making
something up and there and then people
are just repeating it being like yeah
that sounds plausible and you have to
you have their products of their time -
yeah they put them in the context of the
50s and yes in the 80s and what what you
could get away with in the 80s yeah a
satanic panic level lies you could just
lie or listen to what a kid said a kid
said that yeah they flushed me down the
toilet yeah
that was one of my favorite that's
awesome that's awesome when they flush
you down the toilet yeah and then you
appear like I said basement it was just
like in Harry Potter where they go like
they travel like through the portals in
the fireplaces except it's in a toilet a
button
12 molesting [ __ ] Satanists arrived
in a hot-air balloon
I think I would have liked it better if
they'd come in riding on ostriches but
you know that's some of the weird [ __ ]
that's out there today
that I kind of think as plausible isn't
a lot of it isn't isn't paranormal like
all these military bases that we have
like Fort Campbell and you know and you
know Fort Benning and all the other big
military bases are they interconnected
with underground roads that's that that
is actually kind of plausible well
that's not that crazy I mean that seems
like it would be pretty pragmatic if
they're stories about truckers that are
sworn to secrecy and they get in there
there's like two-lane highways over
hundreds of miles from one mean like I
said that wouldn't shock me because that
would be a precedent for that in
strategic yeah there would be a reason
you know an underground an underground
highway system in case of a nuclear
attack in the 50s in the 60s or if they
just had to transport things that they
really really didn't want anybody to
know about it rather than like these
nuclear weapons are maybe they're not
transporting them by truck on the
surface maybe they're transporting them
underneath the ground
yeah there's no chance of hijacking
those trucks yeah so evidently there
came a point according to Nicholls in
one of his books about the Montauk
Project that they decided even though
these experiments had allegedly been
successful I mean they had been able to
do like time travel and all this other
stuff but supposedly they were like no
we shouldn't be messing around with that
which see I don't I don't buy that
because if they did really discover that
stuff they'd be like yeah we need to get
on that ship but according to him
they're like no this is too dangerous we
can't do this anymore so we're just
gonna have to stop the experiment so
evidently there was a contingency plan
so Duncan is in the Vaughn talk chair
like the little psychic electromagnetic
chair someone says to him the time is
now at which point his subconscious
you're gonna love this produced a
monster
what Oh like Forbidden Planet and just
like and just like stranger things where
where where the demo Gorgon is like
you know is a product of Elevens rage I
guess or she was the one that summoned
it with her psychic power there you know
I think that was the implication anyway
so evidently this monster comes out and
it's like stomping all around the base
and eating everything and now the
interesting thing that Nikhil said in
the book was that everyone said they saw
the monster but no one agreed what the
monster looked like so I guess everyone
saw it as different for whatever reason
[Laughter]
so evidently after that happened I don't
know in the book if there was an account
of how they destroyed the monster if it
was really there or what but at this
stage Nichols is like no now we have to
destroy the Montauk chair and evidently
that vanquished the Beast I suppose and
then they just decided they were gonna
shut the whole project down although
that's a cool story kids yeah
although conspiracy theorists say even
though Nikhil says in his book that in
1984 you know the project was stopped
and they filled all the tunnels and
stuff with concrete and blah blah blah
but conspiracy theory theorists still
think that there's something weird going
on at Montauk and like they never really
stopped doing these they just wanted
everybody to think that cuz you know how
that goes and there's really nothing you
can say to argue against people that
think that they're just like you know oh
well they were just brainwashed over
this and then the other thing so as I
said I feel like this is more know now
than it was just because of stranger
things and because it was based on that
because it has like a lot of parallels
to it I mean obviously stranger things
makes a reference to like MKULTRA and
stuff a little bit to which actually did
happen but you know this one sounds a
little out there out there uh you know
yeah the weirdest thing that ever
happens on Air Force Base is really when
you look at the big picture is things
like nuclear weapons nuclear weapons
being places they're not really supposed
to be yeah which is yeah that's not
weird and it's not that weird
now for a certain reason they move some
nuclear weapons for a reason yeah it's
all about because you know they thought
they might have to use them that type of
deal yeah I feel like this and I mean as
as nutty as the Philadelphia Experiment
sounds like with teleporting ships and
like guys like being fused to ship hulls
and stuff I feel like it's a lot a lot
less weird than this stuff supposedly
going out on the Montauk experiments
like oops we birch a hole in space time
there's a wormhole from 43 to 1983
there's like a monster came out started
eating everything on the base and things
of that nature and it's and it's it's a
detailed it's - yeah it's - far-reaching
it's fanfiction it's instructive to that
it seems like everybody that was
supposedly a subject of this series of
experiments only came up with stuff from
oh they were repressed memories they
only came up with stuff like under
hypnosis or they only came up with stuff
after they saw the movie about the
Philadelphia Experiment about it or
something I'm not saying that people's
memories can't be triggered by things
that they see or read because that does
happen sometimes but something that
far-reaching happening to you like when
you were a kid and stuff I feel like
most of the time that could also be a
euphemism for yeah I saw that movie and
I had a really cool idea I had a really
cool idea after I saw that movie yeah I
was there yeah yeah
because I mean some of the people that
came forward later they at like you said
they added [ __ ] on to like other stuff
that other experiments that were going
on at Montauk like oh there was you know
aliens greys obviously because they have
to be brought into everything you know
there was something to do with the
Montauk Monster that's supposedly
unidentified animal that washed up on
the beach in Long Island this is the
kind of case that is believed by people
who want to believe yeah it's too
unlikely yeah yeah and like I said
someone said they saw lizard people some
said they saw this was one of my
favorite quotes quotes extra dimensional
beings that appear in a humanoid shape
made of hollow glass awesome so that's
what's pretty imaginative you know but
so that seems a little weird seems a
little out there I'm not saying that
there's not
aliens there maybe do I think they
visited hmm I doubt it but you know a
big difference between a story like this
yeah and a story like yeah I was sitting
in front of the television I heard a
noise I turn around and I saw my
deceased mother yeah you know and he's
been she vanished yeah you got I mean
that's a that's a common type story yeah
I saw my deceased mother and I felt good
and then she smiled in the cheese she
vanished I'm much more apt to believe in
something like that because that's not
it's crazy that's not completely crazy
it's something that is an experience
that a lot of people have had yeah you
said well what is it is it your
subconscious mind showing you an image
that you needed to see in order to heal
was it a psychic empathic message sent
to you from another dimension where your
mother is now that made you see that
image or was it you know quantum
particles of a soul you know you can
interpret it in many different ways but
still it's just I saw my dead mother
yeah I felt better it's not that
outlandish it's not that outlandish it's
not like we experiment on people and we
brought a ship from 1943 and aliens and
[ __ ] and then we had to go back in time
and it's just too complicated it's too
much like a like a Hollywood movie
script sighs well I'm like I said it
feels like reality doesn't really work
it feels like all of these stories
didn't really come out until people
started seeing the Philadelphia yeah
that totally happened exactly like that
is there so you know I feel like it's
some people that are like a little prone
to fantasy and not that yeah that too
like I said I don't know the intention
like some people might just be crazy and
actually did think that they experienced
what they saw in a movie I think yes
some people might just was back in a
time when you know the media this before
YouTube the media was very restrictive
you know I mean only a certain amount of
people could make it on television and
if you made it on to a TV show you could
make a couple grand yeah so there was
incent
if they come up with stuff with
something like this yeah if you could
get on TV and you had a book to sell you
might make tens of thousands of
thousands of dollars just because of
that one TV appearance and I'm needed on
Geraldo and honestly I feel like - I
think some people like oh well why would
they make that up they didn't make any
money from it I don't think peeps I
don't think some people need to make
that fermented just well I think some
people just like the attention or they
just like to be on TV they don't need
like a financial incentive I don't think
some people just like being the center
of attention I just like being
essentially the case with some of the
UFO witnesses yeah people that said that
they were involved summer just that's
definitely attention but not all of them
yeah not all of them there's some of
those cases even michio kaku said you
can't dismiss some of those cases those
really good ones you can yeah I agree
with that too many witnesses there's
also radar returns and pilots seen all
seeing the same when there's corroborate
it wasn't something there yeah when it's
just one person saying I was in my car
by myself and yeah it's an overweight
middle-aged guy said yes a UFO came in a
beautiful female alien kid and she took
me into the UFO we had sex and I have
children or other planets there was
actually a guy who said that back in the
59 oh and he was the guy weighed 300
pounds yeah
my name is Elmer or some [ __ ] like you
can tell where coveralls and [ __ ] Elmer
said that it's now she had green skin
and eight breasts yeah I would be more
like unlikeliness likely to believe that
that guy was working for the CIA - - you
know what I mean to make the UFO
community look at happen yeah some I
think maybe that might happen sometimes
it's Bobby ie has used the UFO tales as
a cover for secret aircraft experiments
and that way that would be a smart thing
to do yeah when they were just doing
like routine but super secret I was
going through some old UFO documentaries
television documentaries that I had seen
when I was a kid one of them I was
watches oh yeah I remember this one it
was maybe like from 81 or 82 and they
had a woman who was she lived in a
remote area uh I don't remember exact I
think was it was the United States and
she said she heard a sound and turned
around and
saw a UFO coming at her flying low
went right over the little valley she
was in and she saw from the back and
everything that it moved over a head
maybe 250 miles an hour not that fast
she had it drawn she drew it and I'm
looking at it it is definitely the front
end of an f-117 you know what I mean
think yes and it's exactly what she saw
and I was thinking ago yeah that's in
the areas about where they've been even
flying something like right flying it
low and slow which that's what that
thing did 200 miles an hour's slow for
an aircraft and she said it had lights
on blinking lights oh yeah during the
day yeah so it's going like yeah yeah
that's the F oh all right well no
fighter it's you to her like I'm Anna
from the front a stealth fighter looks
like kind of like a jagged UFO yes yeah
a head-on shot and she said it had a V
spikes coming up yeah that's the tail
yeah when it's coming at you right oh
yeah see so I and I feel like there's
there's misidentification to I thinking
that's probably the biggest I think a
lot of the a lot of the claims that
people make I don't necessarily think
that it's them just making stuff up out
of whole cloth I think a lot of times
it's a misattribution or they're seeing
what they want to see Robbie in that
particular case they were talking to
that woman they actually had like you
know she was she was also on the news I
mean they were taking her very seriously
yeah and they had guys from the air
force going did they tell her no of
course oh there was that when it was
secret still oh yeah okay they didn't
tell her she said duh that's a [ __ ]
yeah no no but nowadays nowadays
nowadays yes but she did see what she
said she's sure she did I knew she was
telling truth I saw it ago that stuff
but oh and in 81 you didn't see that
that's just sad because probably like
the rest of her life she thought I
thought UFO but it would have been not
it might not even been 81 I might have
been around 80 yeah her late 7 when that
was d-class I think that might have been
Declassified around 84 yeah it was a
long time ago
because I remember knowing about right
but no they're telling that story I'm
gonna dig that [ __ ] up yeah she shouted
we're gonna [ __ ] still fight I feel bad
for that yeah the Air Force guys gone
dog I hope she knows now or she found
out later so she's just think the aliens
were coming to visit in the plane all
right anyway so that's this show's gone
on far too long already so let's wrap
this up hope you guys enjoyed our kind
of rambling look we're always rambling
the philadelphia philadelphi experiment
didn't happen cool story but it didn't
happen the way they said it did maybe
inspired by something that Allende saw
his name yeah or Carl Allen I think was
his real name but he went my car was
spent Hispanic version of yeah that was
that was like the most interesting man
in the world version of himself kind of
creative in a little bit maybe you know
slightly you know schizophrenic and well
that's supposedly thought he's
schizophrenic and he came up with camel
it was a cool story yeah maybe he kind
of saw but it wasn't an experiment and
some other lunatics came in and came up
with it after seeing a movie about that
blew it up into something even bigger
and make us at a time orbiting within
glass people yeah and aliens and
interdimensional stuff you know and a
chair that like ramps up your psychic
abilities right I wish this chair did
that it does all kinds of cool ok so
just remember if you like the show
do you like share subscribe on all your
social media share with all your friends
relatives and even people you don't like
we can be used as punishment also if
you'd like to financially support the
show you can go to our patreon page at
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcast or
you can go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast wordpress calm and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account if you'd like to give a
one-time donation remember to check out
our last movie review which was the
howling and if you haven't seen our new
little show which is called
13 o'clock
okay where we review three new movies
that we see every week then check that
out I'm gonna try and put up new
episodes every Sunday of all the new
movies that we saw in the theaters this
week and also if you would like your
Halloween stories fiction or nonfiction
read on our Halloween show please try to
get them to me before the 19th because
we're gonna be recording sometime
between the 19th and the 21st the
Halloween shows is this kind of your
last chance if you want to send us some
stuff send it to grave cake at gmail.com
and that will do it for episode 113 we
will see you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]